I love the last of us one last of us one
was an instant classic you like the Last
of Us one yeah it's good formula Joel
and Ellie that's winning duo right there
[Music]
The Last of Us two to the Last of Us -
by its title it's the sequel to The Last
of Us Last of Us came out in 2013
seven years ago time flies so now we
have the Last of Us - it's four years
later Ellie is it's a it's a
coming-of-age story for Ellie I feel
like I'm getting right into it but
spoiler free it's gonna be really hard
talking about this game with no spoilers
but that's what this video is this a
spoiler free so I'm gonna have to do a
spoiler talk for it to really dive into
it so if I'm vague about some points
apologies but wait for the spoiler talks
oh yeah Ellie is out there she's on a
quest you play as Ellie for half the
game then you play as a character named
Abby and now we have the Last of Us 2
which takes place in Seattle funny
enough so I actually had fun because
Pacific Northwest that's me so I had fun
seeing what they got right what looks
similar what looks different I mean not
just different because it's destroyed
it's the apocalypse welcome to Chaz
although sometimes I was like how long
is this apocalypse been going on to get
what trees have grown in the streets
that's a bus stop how did trees grow in
the streets apocalypse in this game has
been going on for 20 years it looks more
than 200 I digress it actually does look
very similar to the Seattle Convention
Center though that should be the
Cheesecake Factory right there but I get
it licensing issues feel like we're
getting a little off track here point is
you play as Ellie and a new character
named Abby I now enter a lot of what's
very similar in terms of gameplay from
the Last of Us one if you played The
Last of Us one you can jump right into
the gameplay it's not exact Oh new
mechanic you get to go prone now to hide
from enemies I'm glad they implemented a
mechanic that Metal Gear 2 had in 1990
it's pretty much the same but bigger and
longer so a lot more walking around and
scrounging for parts that actually did
get old usually I talk about what I
liked in the game what I didn't but
since we're on the subject yeah going
around opening drawers and scrounging
for parts is most of what again I know
you did that in the first one but maybe
that's wise cause like
I did that in the first one now I'm
doing it in here and at a point I was
like I am done scrounging for garbage
but I kept doing it I don't know if it
was just because I was conditioned or I
actually wanted to upgrade my stuff but
I was at a point I was like I just want
to kill monsters and get to the end of
this story but I don't think it's
necessarily good for a game to evoke
that kind of response to the game or
gaming in the world but that's what
happened got a little tedious at parts
but I'm telling you the graphics in this
game we're in the final timeframe of
this console generation so they know how
to make it look like business The Last
of Us - does look like business and with
that comes the atmosphere in the tone
that's really what I love most about The
Last of Us it's Resident Evil which The
Last of Us one came out when Resident
Evil turned into action games Capcom was
like now people like action they don't
like survival horror anymore and the
Last of Us was like hey hate to tell you
you're wrong but you are
and now Resident Evil's gone back to
survival horror so it looks like
Resident Evil it looks like The Last of
Us is survival horror with great
atmosphere great tones some of these
monsters just kind of scurry across the
ground and stalk you'd use your
flashlight down this dingy ass hallway
looks like Silent Hill [ __ ] a hotel and
now you're in it for nothing else
gameplay wise it's a fun stealth game
it's just really fun going around
stealth killing enemies sure they're
idiots a lot of the time and they lack
any sense of peripheral vision but
Ellie's probably better known to the
locals as Baba Yaga because holy [ __ ]
her body count
is business I just felt badass going
around stealth killing douchebags
although this one's [ __ ]
that's a headshot okay how big you are
[Music]
actually there's one scene in particular
one of these fights where you got to
push the button at the right time and
dodge and attack and this thing is messy
it gets nasty and by the end you have
the answer to that question what I know
look at these scars I know now I do know
the answer to that Joker cuz I played
The Last of Us - long story short I
really enjoy my time in the world of The
Last of Us and that's where we come to
that double-edged sword thing where as
Ellie story is much more linear going
from point A to point B Abby's story is
the story that actually takes me around
and lets me see more of this world I so
enjoy which I feel like there might have
been some skillful manipulation right
there in order to have you accept this
new character and want to play as a be
because right out the gate Abi's kind of
starting out on the wrong foot with you
because Abby did a bad bad thing
spoiler-free
wait for the spoiler talks so I feel
like there was a very conscious effort
to go okay
Ellie's story a little more linear just
going from point A to point B Abby we
get to see more of the world it's it's a
little more interesting the world you
see through Abby's eyes is more
interesting it has more to do with the
different factions and the conflicts
among them I really dug that but I feel
like they work very consciously like
okay we'll make Abby's quest a little
more interesting with the world then
Ellie's is also will make a be a little
more personable than Ellie I mean I
thought Ellie's relationship with her
girlfriend that was sweet but in the end
I'm like why is this girl dating Ellie I
mean this is at least just I get it she
has a lot on her shoulders but as much
as you want to converse when you're out
there on a quest she doesn't really she
was that person who gives like two word
answers
she's korben Dallas on ruby rods show so
tell me my man
but Abby's very personable you can hang
out with Abbi and I think that was very
consciously done we're like we'll make a
be more interesting than Ellie also make
her world more interesting than the
world you see with Ellie BAM there you
go you have no choice but to accept a B
now that's not to say I don't like Ellie
I'm already attached to Ellie because of
the first game so this game being
Ellie's quest I was there for that I
actually enjoyed the fact that Ellie's
coming into her own and it's actually
her quest she's not in anyone's shadow I
think that needed to happen with Ellie I
don't think it needed to happen the way
it happens they could have had Ellie go
out on her own quest in one of a metric
[ __ ] Tilian ways they chose this one but
regardless and Ellie coming into her own
this being her coming-of-age story you
feel it she's brash she's flawed but she
takes the hits and quite literally has
the bruises to show it as you see is one
scene where she takes her shirt off
you're like you are beaten which say
what you want about the catalyst that
starts her out on her quest and I
understand the point is when she's out
there on her quest it's blood sweat and
tears and credit where credit's due
I appreciate that however not only does
the game feel a little tedious and you
scrounging for trinkets and trash to
make gear and bombs and get pills to get
upgrades but the game kind of feels
uneven you play as Ellie's arc and that
arc is coming to a head and then halfway
through the game it's like alright now
you're Abby and it kind of feels like it
does this control-alt-delete of momentum
the momentum is climbing with Ellie and
then boom you're back at the beginning I
mean not Ellie's beginning but now it's
Abby's story but you start out having to
search for gear again and get gun
upgrades again it's kind of like imagine
you you go through three days of an
event doing something whatever it is you
pick and then after day three you wake
up it was all a dream
you got to do it again but it felt like
that it just you feel the momentum just
grind to a halt
I get why they're doing it though
they're doing it for reasons I can't
really touch on here but the reasons the
concepts it's not as new I think it is I
mean
questions they want the audience the
gamer to ask and experience these are
these are age-old questions that have
been in countless movies and plays books
TV shows doesn't quite stick the landing
for me I felt like I was playing The
Last of Us three like there's an entire
other game out there that took place in
between 1 and 2 that I just missed in
the end it's like the director of The
Last of Us - Neil druckmann sadly yeah
I'm expecting this to divide the fanbase
I feel like I'm paraphrasing but he said
something like that which is always it's
a funny thing when I hear that only in
entertainment can you hear someone be
like yeah I'm totally cool with just 50%
of people saying that [ __ ] that I get
doing things that where you're like
that'll take a small hit but being cool
of 50 is just crazy but he is not wrong
and I feel like this could have actually
worked out better for me personally
anyway there'd a lot of people out there
who love this game I myself enjoyed
things about it but I I enjoyed the last
of us one more just maybe I'm just a
traditionalist I just fundamentally
think the Last of Us one was in the
pocket it was just a tighter story
that's that the graphics are great the
atmosphere is really good survival
horror the world looks gorgeous have not
destroyed the battle mechanics I enjoyed
the scrounging gets a little tedious and
in the end I felt the ending was just a
bit anticlimactic to me just was for the
ending it's not just that it's long it's
it's long winded you know like it's a
speech that someone has and they're
talking forever and you're like all
right you made your point and then they
keep talking and you you're like all
right your point just kind of got lost
that's the ending to the Last of Us - at
a point if it just cut right there but
like that's the end it would have been
fine then it went on for so long I was
like all right now I'm just I'm kind of
not buying this you'll either enjoy it
just fine or hate it entirely because of
a direction it takes at a point pretty
early on there's enjoyment in here
gameplay wise I'll say it's worth buying
at stale price
all right that's the spoiler free stuff
on to the spoiler review that'll come
around Friday ish not enough Friday
weekend you know the worst thing about
this game seriously like the thing I had
the hardest time with was killing the
dogs or dogs that could sniff out your
trail you gotta you gotta take the dogs
out I hate
it's the worst part of the entire game
it's this Neil druckmann is a cat person
that's what I learned I actually respect
how dark and real that [ __ ] was but
still poor dogs alright so the last of
us to have you played it what did you
think about it no spoilers in the
comment section please I feel like I'm
asking for it actually I'll just tell
people if you don't want spoilers stay
away from this comment section wait for
the spoiler talk I feel like most of you
good people out there you won't put
spoilers in the comments there's always
people out there just trying to ruin the
party that's that the spoiler is dumb
but why did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
[Music]